le triomphe de la motoneige sur les
éléments dans les rues de montréal
c'était le 4 mars 1971 et le maire jean
drapeau avait un conseil avisé la
tempête du siècle laisse 50 centimètres
en deux jours et laisse aussi beaucoup
de souvenirs ça nous avait donné congé
pendant quelques jours et puis qu'on a
cherché notre voiture aussi pendant deux
jours parce qu'elle était sous la neige
dans la rue puis on n'avait pas aussi
sur ski-doo sans s'en rendre compte
à certains endroits la neige s'accumule
et jusqu'au panneau des noms de rue il y
aura aussi dix sept victimes dont
plusieurs crises cardiaques en pelle
dans la neige à sherbrooke pour la
saint-valentin 2007 64 cm pas mal mais à
moncton en 1992 il a fallu creuser des
tunnels pour entrer dans les bâtiments
et là aussi la motoneige et thérèse il
faut dire qu'il était tombé 161 cm de
neige en 33 heures plus qu'il n'en faut
pour ensevelir une personne de taille
moyenne
impossible d'oublier la tempête de mars
2017 et son célèbre fiasco de
l'autoroute 13 et ces naufragés qui ne
seront évacués qu'au bout de la nuit
parce que nous avons on est bien content
à mon honneur d'arriver à maison
plus loin de chez nous il y à cette
route emprisonné sous 7 mètres de neige
dans les alpes
on est en montagne ont pas oublié des
murs de neige qui rappellent ceux du
japon de vue d attraction touristique à
part entière
il faut aussi rappeler le blizzard de
2016 sur la côte est américaine
la neige fraîche est toujours très bien
accueillis par certains que ce soit sur
une planche ou simplement sur le doubs
est sans grosse tempête de neige il n'y
aurait pas ça ici mathieu prost radio
canada c'est lui